bonsoir mon frère martin surpris
si vous avez construite cette maison
absolument vous même de mes blanchemain
l'empannage vous êtes justement dans la
partie qui n'est pas qu'il n'ait pas été
construite si une qui n'est pas terminée
à qui n'est pas terminée c'est plus la
partie que j'ai trouvé en arrivant oui
c'est un parti que j'ai trouvé
effectivement la non mais c'est pas là
oui c'est bien c'était de la terre
battue
vous avez fait ça tout ça mais c'est un
challenge et pourquoi on n'est pas
construite au bord de la mer plutôt que
dans ce quartier bas parce que les prix
du terrain était un peu élevées au mois
de septembre j'ai commencé ouais donc
j'ai pensé à ces vous en prie donc j'ai
pensé qu' il fallait que je m'adapte à
la situation ouais et j'ai eu beaucoup
de chance figurez-vous puisqu'on parle
de la maison c'est que les usines olida
ont été démolies et j'ai l'autorisation
de récupérer tout ce que je voulais
alors les poutres métalliques les
piliers les deux viennent sur l'ida et
d'un studio de cinéma qui a aussi fermé
ses portes derrière weepu chez vous et
moi aussi laissé prendre ce que je
voulais vous avez fait combien quand
même livre une trentaine de boucliers 32
33 ouais mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il ya une ligne directive inter qu'un
livre appelle toujours l'autre par
exemple le premier est qu à pourvoir est
le premier français s'est vu ça marche
pas et veut pas le premier festive sur
le suicide ouais pourquoi parce que vous
étiez oui oui j'ai fait un suicide
positif il faut être constructif vous
avez essayé de me suicider quand vous
êtes sceptiques en mai j'ai pensé
beaucoup mais parce que parce que le
geste me plaisait vous connaissez la
formule de proue tollé duhaime les les
héros qui meurent jeunes quand on n'est
pas lyon de ses déboires sûr on peut le
devenir de manière alors de c'était le
premier sens fige en effet 4 c'était
prévu sur ce prix en faisant de livres
sur celui-ci je me lève sur ce site qui
disait quoi prononcée par un mode
d'emploi ça c'était beaucoup plus tard
c'était pas vous non c'était pas mal ce
n'est pas un mode d'emploi c'est un tour
de la question ça s'appelle r2 de
socrate à montherlant ça oui c'est une
des grands suisses et
et en faisant cette enquête je me suis
aperçu que les mains se suicider plus
que le reste de la population dont on
fait en france ouais parce que c'est pas
du tout pareil au brésil parce que j'ai
été les voir au brésil et là ils sont
animés au contraire d'un sentiment de
supériorité tout à fait extraordinaire
et ils ont comme mascotte un géant qui
promène avec une laisse lors de recours
et annuaires dans cet univers quoi
secouer et l'association a quand même
quinze mille membres
dirigé par un grand poète brésilien
s'appelle morales et leurs études ils
font des études dans l'étude consiste à
approuver que tout ce qui a été fait de
bien dans le monde a été fait par des
petits seins c'est bien et là quand je
me suis rendu donc au brésil les
rencontres et le les travaux sur la
table était le christ mesurait moins
d'un mètre soixante donc c'était ça il
est en contact avec le vatican et en
france donc les mains ces suicides plus
que votre vie vous avez fait les mains
donc j'ai fait un livre sur lennar
faisant l'ena je me suis aperçu que
c'était vraiment une la toute petite
population de d'un monde extraordinaire
qui s'appelle les monstres donc ensuite
j'ai refait le tour du monde quoi
commence vous avez après tout j'ai suivi
la nomenclature de geoffroy
saint-hilaire film commentateur du 19e
siècle mais qui est bonne encore
aujourd'hui qui est même la seule
valable et j'ai fait deux premiers types
de monstres là vous avez les monstres
unitaire où les monstres les monstres
double ou composer on va dire dans les
monstruosités vous allez monstre par
excès les gérants vous allez montez par
défaut les nains et dans les monstres
composé alors tout ce que votre
imagination on peut peut entrevoir la
nature a fait mieux et plus beau
des gens qui ont eu des têtes de moutons
n'ont jamais quand même nom mêlé les
forains ont donné des noms d'animaux à
des monstres parce que le particularisme
le particularisme physique rappelait
effectivement tout à l'heure ça vous
intéresse je montrerai la femme pas
moins récession vers la femme cham all
away mais voulait alors non pour finir
votre question que j'aille au bout donc
des monstres si vous voulez je j'ai
rencontré des vies absolument
extraordinaire que je souhaite à tous
les gens que j'aime et notamment dans
dans la guerre donc j'ai fait dans le
dans le combat dans la force physique et
j'ai fait donc un livre sur sur les
duels c'était la suite logique le jeu
avec la mort m'a poussé ensuite entre
voir rencontrer des grands destins de
monstres comptés comme des pros c'est
sensationnel notamment des siamois alors
est-ce qu'on devait tuer les deux
éléments qui ont commis des maris
absolument extraordinaire donc là il ya
eu chez lui oui voilà eh bien je vais
vous dire que par exemple
henri iv dans sa grande sagesse avait
dit laissons découvrir ah ouais mais
qu'en italie il ya une quinzaine
d'années pour la première fois de toute
l'histoire de la justice italienne le
tribunal a dû revenir sur une source
jugée parce que il ya eu ça vous amuse y
raconte en deux minutes ainsi à moi il
sait les chanteurs
s'étaient les chanteurs et donc il
faisait les bals musettes italien et il
y en a qui buvait beaucoup mais il avait
des connexions une connexion avec le
foie qui faisait quand il ya un qui
buvait l'eau traitée ont aussi aimé
c'est toujours le même qui conduisait
bien évidemment ils ont raison ils ont
renversé une petite fille ils l'ont tué
donc ils sont passés en justice et la
justice a dit les a condamnés à la
capitale et une rente à vie le frère il
dit moi je veux bien dire que j'étais
aussi je ne conduisais pas donc si si si
bon si je dois payer une pension moi
j'arrête de travailler alors celui qui
était coupable dit si lui arrêtent de
travailler obligé aussi donc je n'ai
plus de raison d'être dans la vie je me
suicide
d oui mais si celui-ci dit me tue aussi
à ceux est sûre ce chantage la justice
est revenu sur la chose jugée a décidé
que chaque toile un peu plus importants
allaient suffire à régler à faire là
c'est d'oser faire un livre aussi sur
les animaux des animaux de guerre non
oui les animaux les animaux
employés dans les conflits armés c'est
ce à quoi les chevaux et d'anciens j'ai
eu un formidable il ya les pigeons il y
avait des gens vous avez les quads
autres les laissera pour détecter le gaz
nantes harnes long c'est fini ça depuis
si on veut sans fin fonde way deux
bogeys ratant
non ils vous avez les éléphants qui ont
été très résultant dans l'artillerie et
que les américains ont même utilisé au
vietnam et les français d'indochine
aussi on avait des unités d'éléphants ce
qui est déjà salée pendant vos jamais ça
aux actualités c'est dommage ça serait
bon c'est vrai enfin vous le verrez dans
mon livre avait volant et c'est en fait
il est une pareille dans quinze jours ah
oui vous avez avant avec des photos de
zahia 300 bateaux est l'animal le plus
bizarre qui était utilisé dans
chacun ses frontières du bizarre mais je
dirais que étonnant pour beaucoup vous
avez les chauves-souris bombardier ah
bon vous avez le visa et les rapports y
fort les gens pourraient fort que ça
veut dire ça veut dire c deja qu on
transforme en torche vivante et puis
qu'on lance
ça c'était beaucoup utilisé par la carte
14 pour mettre le feu aux fourrages
allemand 1
et puis au vietnam on essaie des trucs
tout à fait étonnant on a essayé les les
les alarmes vivante et on a admis sur le
terrain des moustiques parce qu'on a
cherché quel était le plus grand
prédateur de l'homme allons essayer
options les plus
légères et on s'est aperçu que des
boosts ici réserves et des combattants
non mais c'est que dans mes plus le
moustique s'énervait profondément kanté
sentais sale à sa proie de prédilection
qu'est l'homme à environ 25 mètres et se
mettait dans une sorte de transe donc
les chercheurs américains il faut
absolument en capter cette france donc
ça nous avertir à de présence donc c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait des
espèces de barrières de moustiques de
barrières on va dire oui ou non pas plus
que ça de postes de garde alarme vivante
je pensais que c'était juste les
moustiques étaient utilisés pour piquer
le nom là on a mieux n'avait les m16 et
tout mais là c'est intéressant pisan
abandonné le ils ont abandonné le site
alarme parce qu'il n'arrivait pas
détecté dans quelle direction se dirige
l effet domino c'est utiliser les
dauphins comme arme de guerre en avez
vous appris est ce que les gens savent
plus où mettre des propos mettre des
bombes sous les bateaux des trucs à 1946
fait droit les premiers confessa
exactement avec les avec les phoques et
là le le floch malheureusement sauter
avec sa charge ensuite les soviétiques
ont fait la même chose avec lui avec les
chiens et le chien sauter avec la charge
ils étaient dressés aller chercher en
nourriture kelly case chaque année sauf
que le kamikaze est volontaire et que le
cher le chien n'a été simplement affamés
ça qu'il allait chercher sa nourriture
avec une antenne qui met qui étaient là
qui touchait le char et qui faisait
exploser la charge et qui donc
immobilisé le
après on s'est aperçu que le dressage de
ces animaux coûte une fortune sont venus
très précieux là on a fait attention de
ne pas les perdre mais c'est quoi votre
vrai métier quoi il ya écrit quoi ils
servent à quoi oui moi non je suis
journaliste huawei
je l'aï vu l'autre jour au lieu de faire
un article sur cinq feuillets je le fais
sur 800 feuillets mais c'est la même
tragédie le temps comment vous faites
tout le temps mais j'adore ça vous vivez
tout seul ici non
j'ai une épouse qui est dans son livre
d'or rose bien c'est beau et donc ça
tout seul alors tout ça ça ça vient de
coucher les poutres viennent de chez
olida
les fenêtres viennent d'un magasin c'est
de garder bien oui oui vous survivez
très très bien sur cette terre
finalement un oui mais surtout je fais
les choses passionnantes mais surtout
surtout ça hein vous avez vos photos
d'eux lui par devoir alors qu'est ce que
vous voulez voir par débattre je sais
pas je vais voir les animaux ou des
animaux alors les animaux pouvoir tout
va bien on a beaucoup donné
je vous en montrer quelques unes
spécifiques les hommes sages et un
cheval qui a été décoré par l'armée
allemande pour son courage et son
courage au fond c'est pas évident
je vous ai fait un truc sur les moyens
de tuer des gens j'ai fait un livre oui
que j'espère de référence oui ça
seulement voilà sur toutes les façons de
tuer les gens et c'est vous qui allez ça
que si on a inventé le droit interne
hâtif et que je sa jeune histoire c'est
le
edison est présenté dans tous les autres
dans toutes les encyclopédies où les
livres pour les jeunes comme
saint-homme bienfaiteur de l'humanité
c'est vrai en partie mais pas seulement
on le présente également comme
abolitionnistes c'est totalement faux il
a participé à l'histoire de l'appel
demande façon très active il y avait une
lutte sourde aux états unis pour équiper
le territoire américain une l'eau d'une
lutte industriels edison était partisan
du courant continu et un autre
westinghouse lui faisait du courant
alternatif
pour prouver que le courant alternatif
était dangereux parce qu'à l'époque il
ya eu plus de 500 morts parmi les types
qui travaillait à ce qui est
l'équivalent d'edf pour prouver que
c'était dangereux edison a commencé une
campagne de presse abominable contrôle
westinghouse en dix ans ont procédé est
terrible regardez plus de 500 accidents
cinq ans etc et il a commencé à faire
des tournées en amérique en
électrocutant avec le courant de watts
d'alternative dans de westinghouse des
animaux de plus en plus gros
méconnaissable alors non des chevaux des
modes équation et puis il ya eu il ya
dans l'état de new york il ya eu une
histoire qu une pendaison s'était
déroulée de façon affreuse parce que
l'accord doit être absolument
proportionnée au poids de l'individu à
son âge a ses caractéristiques
physiologiques à la résistance de ses
hauts et ses bas une ficelle est ce que
sinon soit vous mourrez étouffé soit la
tête et arraché il faudrait donc à
l'accord donné trop fine et la tête avec
voilà il ya vu capita spécialement donc
il ya vu quelque chose d'abominable et
tout le congrès américain se disait il
faut changer les moyens de tuer faut
trouver quelque chose de tuer une vanne
façon très proprement et aussi là où ça
fait venir saint coran ou tang
thaïlande c'est à l'époque elles avaient
encore organisé une électrocution de 1
de 50 ans devant tout le congrès et le
le projet a été adopté en face youn et
collectionner comme ça enfin je vais un
peu vite et a nommé quelqu'un pour faire
des études ensuite c'est prenant tous
les états unis ont besoin d
électrocution l'ont prouvé que son
concurrent avait un courant tu en voilà
il a pris la promue en fait le courant
alternatif grâce à la chaise électrique
est il à l inventaire de ses lectrices
est l'inventeur non seulement ses
inventeurs mais c'est là où les choses
deviennent un peu douteuse à son sujet
c'est que il a participé donc à la
création de la première chaise qui a
exécuté un dénommé kremer mais ensuite
il a participé à toutes les expériences
sur cinq condamnations à mort pour le
positionnement des électrodes et c'est
lui même qui disait on va essayer le
front et le poignet ensuite ils disent
on va essayer le coeur et la cheville et
c'est lui qui a quand même mener ses
expériences en tant qu'expert alors que
je des fois je m'élève un peu quand on
traite d'abolitionnistes grain vous ai
fait un truc sur les excréments sinon je
suis en train
ouais ça si vous êtes en train de bosser
là dessus je suis les gens qui peignent
avec des excréments c'est ça donc ça
c'est pour le petit chapitre concernant
le concernant l'art
concernant l'art l'art est vraiment oui
mais là j'ai fini le
lan tête sur le sur la médecine et les
extrêmement alors ça c'est des gens qui
boivent de lure in par exemple communes
comme une médication ou absolument c'est
vrai ça oui bien sûr ça marche je vous
avais plus de 2 me abass l'euro ça
marche mais attendez livre ça va arriver
en france ouais vous avez plus de deux
millions et demi de d'adeptes au japon
vous avez 300 400 milles aux états unis
vous avez déjà 60 me en allemagne 50
milles en angleterre ça va arriver en
france en angleterre et en allemagne à
une émission une production sans fil
émission d'une heure elle a reçu
tellement de coups de téléphone a eu un
tel succès qu'ils ont re diffusé une
heure de grande écoute son émission elle
a sorti un livre qui aurait directement
de ses missions elle en a vendu 300
mille exemples c'est soigner vous avec
votre urine cru mort mais alors vu vont
peut-être un peu fort parce que si vous
les écoutez moi je vis leur déclaration
ça soit strictement tout du moins c'est
toujours pareil mais
il ya quand même quelque chose avec lui
rinne c'est que les les médicaments les
plus vendus dans le monde sont faibles
de leurs inhumaines vous avez des
groupes américains qui paye tout lennon
des monastères français espagnol pour
récolter récup et c'est vrai ce de
l'uriné de femmes ménopausées pour
fabriquer des médicaments contre la la
fierté pour la fertilité ou des
médicaments mains des médicaments
beaucoup plus courant que ça qui se
fabriquent avec de l'uriné de cheval du
dribble et bien sûr durer une semaine
voilà ça c'est la maquette de celui qui
va sortir ils sont que dans 15 juin
oui l'ordonnancé l'intérieur c'est
l'intérieur d'un autre bien sûr c'est la
maquette d'épaisseur alors si vous à ces
suicides
alors là vous avez des documents
absolument incroyable bien sûr la peine
de mort vous a vu
vous bossez comme en commun que vous
appréciez ne vois rien dans tout
ça c'est une mode saas et toutes les
peines de mort c'est quoi la peine de
mort la plus extraordinaire il ya
beaucoup de pays on peut être nous on
croit toujours tous les pays ont
supprimé la peine de mort en fait il ya
quoi il ya encore 90 % des gens qui
sourit verts qui semblent si ces raisons
d'être
j'ai besoin d'y penser un peu plus la
sueur mondial peu son allégeance à face
à énoncer mais savent pas s'ils savent
pas qu'ils aient une recrudescence et
que les pays abolitionnistes sont en
train de rétablir oui c'est aussi en
excès pour brésil au brésil 3-0
philippines en colombie vous pouvez
servir en france la dame en août et les
gens disent ce n'est pas possible en
réalité ça serait possible puisqu'on a
signé une convention
une convention avec
européenne sur ce sujet mais qui n'était
valable que cinq ans les gens croient
qu'on a signé pour vite et a meta en
réalité
et poussa pourrait commence à pouvoir
commence alors commencera pas sur terre
la façon la plus étonnante que vous ayez
trouvé de tuer légalement ses
concitoyens c'est quoi et bien c'est
peut-être il faut que la vie il faut que
cette peine soit inscrit dans un code 1
pourquoi les considérations parce que
sinon les choses abominables née d'un
esprit malade on peut en trouver mais là
plus à la plus la plus subtile ne
peut-être que j'ai trouvé c'est une
peine inscrit dans le code chinois qui a
disparu mais pas depuis longtemps qui a
disparu depuis peut-être 30 ans qui
consistait à mettre un condamné à mort
dans un dans un tonneau jusqu'aux
aisselles way
dans ce tour hui et de la chaux lâche
aux poudres et ensuite on lui mettait
autour de lui de la nourriture très
salée du poisson de 1 des viandes très
sale et des viandes séchées c est autant
d'eau qu'il voulait donc immédiatement
plongé au bout de trois quatre jours
même si ce raté fils et parlant j'ai
donc il devait boire beaucoup elles sont
les deux vo rin et ils urinaient dans la
chaux la source se transformer au chaud
vive ouais donc donc commencé que le
manger quoi qu'ils ont mangé de la deux
rôles de l'intérieur avait duré quinze
jours trois semaines un mois et ça
c'était assez tessinois ça va aller
c'est très très violentes mais là
c'était dans le code c'était prévu
c'était on peut être condamné à cinq ans
de ciment a mis d'accord et votre
bouquin sur lémance
assez bons il vient de vie vient de
ressortir leur
nom c'est l'ancienne édition la nouvelle
édition chedjou
et voilà le celui sur les nains qui a
été le le le prologue si vous voulez à
celui là hommes tête de veau à huy
retrouvez toutes les photos de j'étais
aux états unis toutes les photos dans
les musées des cirques dans les anciens
managers voilà face à nice mignon c'est
joli ou fameux homard
l'as extraordinaire
alors ça c'est des monstres 5 mai dans
les monstres double vous avez des choses
tout à fait extraordinaire
est ce que dévoile à des foyers des ja
c'est à moi mais l'autre n'est pas de la
même taille que le premier s'appelle
parce que quand les siamois quand les
surfaces des tâches entièrement ouais ça
donne des jumeaux ouais mais il arrive
que la séparation se fasse pas
entièrement un don vous avez deux
identiques ouais ce sont les siamois
commencent les imagine d'habitude mais
tout peut être possible ces terres que
les deux seins peuvent se confondre vers
le bas à sont là vous avez deux thorax
de tête quand les bras de joie ou et de
jambes ou alors au contraire se
confondre
oui comme cela là voilà franck lentilles
par exemple il ya trois ans non
et il a il a inspiré d'ailleurs harel et
des fois quand même c'est très très
bizarre alors lui valent un globe deux
visages confondent valent à l'ancien ces
deux siamois presque confondues la 3e et
des données mais en fait c'est une
question de superposition jean-luc leur
squelette de siamois
alors tout ça est mort en 1945 ça c'est
une destinée franco lé frère long qui
dit
mais qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent en
général les siamois et bien coûter jusqu
en 1940 ils ont eu des destinées
incroyable puisqu'ils étaient tous sous
contrat avec les grands grand cirque
américain ah ouais donc ils sont tous
devenus milliardaires à 1 c'est ça qui
en faisait du fric oui j'ai bien sûr ah
là là je dois l'argent constitue par
exemple la vie ça c'est la première
opération siamois qui a eu en france en
1910 ah oui là il n'y a pas beaucoup à
faire par exemple justement on pouvait
pas avoir ce sont les deux qui ont donné
le nom de siamois à cette spécificité
monstrueuse vous avez un froid commun et
à l'époque on ne savait pas à quelle foi
1 avec des essais de les séparer il y en
a qui ont des enfants et tout ça oui
tous par exemple dans freaks le prince
mendiants cesser le mettrons convoi
ramper sous la neige dans la nuit dans
l'eau son chariot jours de pluie pas de
bras pas de jambes justin tranter il
avait une femme quatre enfants et quatre
filles sublimes et le jour de son
enterrement à new york il ya deux cent
mille personnes et ça n'enlève et jolie
sept films donc ça c'est l'utilisation
de là une utilisation qui est faite par
un appareil photo alors l'utilisation
des mots des marques commerciales de la
forme monstrueuse par les marques
commerciales mais c'est une vraie cll
c'est dans ces avantages ces avantages
c'est ce que le très joli c'est dans le
chapitre des amis à la télévision en vue
d'accords rue
je passerais bien la nuit avec vous et
que l'on est sûr de ne rien rater
inler du tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu